foreign
[Music]
in london ontario there lives a man
whose basement is unlike anything you've
ever seen
this is robert wardoff hi my name is
robert wordoff robert has been playing
the same dungeons and dragons campaign
for over 30 years 35 years to be exact
i'm sorry that's okay
welcome would you like to play a dwarven
rogue
you look like a rogue wait let's back up
for a second dungeons and dragons is a
fantasy role playing game where a group
of people come together and play out
adventures dictated by a dungeon master
these adventures also known as campaigns
are set in the dungeons and dragons
world and normally have an endpoint or
they just fizzle out due to people's
lack of commitment but robert is in a
league of his own and here's why
the dude has a serious collection i
think our collection of miniatures is
around 20 000
and then over the years i discovered
terrain ultimately i'm a collector also
and a lot of my enjoyment comes from
being able to get new stuff and to put
new stuff on the table so the players
are constantly coming across new
settings
because it's a game that doesn't stick
to one particular campaign setting i'm
able to use any figs that actually fit
the world
and so it is a long process but over 35
years
you could develop quite a collection as
robert's collection grew so did the
number of players word began to spread
about the never ending campaign we have
people coming from all over the country
to play off and flying in wait all over
the country that's right
robert can we play now
these are some of the people who play in
robert's game where are you guys from
i flew in from saskatoon saskatchewan i
drove in from toronto brussels ontario
camoca ontario calgary alberta hold on
what happens if people can't fly in or
drive to robert's house to play
hey everyone
problem solved
[Music]
the game has always been determined
really through friendship it's really
been a way that i keep my friends
together i knew early on that if i was
able to create a game that was good
enough and that means it had to be
better than video games it had to be
better than any other game they could
find that they would keep coming no
matter where i was and so that takes
again imagination and it takes change
and it takes having a system that is
constantly dynamic that is changing that
is growing and that is constantly
getting better
[Applause]
without abraham lincoln and really his
beard milton bradley the godfather of
board games would have never existed
bold statement i know but let me explain
[Music]
the game of life
the spinner the cars the choices college
or career kids or no kids lawyer or
farmer this family game night staple was
once a pretty morbid game
back in the 1800s milton bradley was in
the lithograph business following the
republican national convention of 1860
bradley printed thousands of images of
abraham lincoln who was clean-shaven at
the time shortly thereafter lincoln
debuted his iconic beard rendering all
of bradley's prince worthless
his lithograph business went belly up
so bradley was forced to try something
new he came up with a board game a
seemingly dark and twisted board game
appropriately named the checkered game
of life the game functioned in a similar
way to how it does now there was a
spinner colored circles that moved
around the board and of course squares
that could either make you or break you
the squares on the original game were
overwhelmingly grim boasting actions
like disgrace poverty ruin crime prison
and well suicide
regardless the game flew off the shelves
kids loved it and milton bradley went on
to own family game night fast forward to
about 100 years later they revamped the
game trading bradley's morbid squares
for the more delightful ones like payday
or graduation which we have all come to
know and love and so there you have it
the story of the game called life
[Music]
settlers of catan is one of the best
selling board games of all time
and nestled in the rolling hills of
rossdorf germany
on this picturesque street
past the buzzer in building 43 and
standing in the back of the garden is
klaus tuber
the man who made it all happen
[Music]
settlers of katan is a board game for up
to four players where you collect
resources to build settlements and
cities
they're worth points first to 10 wins
and it all started like this
in the 90s and 80s
i led a dental laboratory
developing games was a little bit
refuge for me
his first game was called barbarossa
when i made barbarossa i was in my early
30s i feel that this is a kind of thing
i like very much developing games and it
could be in the future for me a
very very good hobby
he designed a handful of other games and
then
made katan
klaus had become interested in viking
tales yes the story of the vikings
inspired me i imagine how they reach
iceland they need wood they need houses
and all the things and so on this
imagination
i developed qatar
from design to market it was a family
affair
this is benny tuber he lives in germany
and he is klaus's youngest son
and this is guido tuber
and this is guido tuber he lives in san
francisco he is klaus's eldest son
in my family i am one of the game
testers along with my mom
me too
we play tested the settlers of catan
quite often
we would all get together at the dining
room table and would test and
has his games
sometimes he put a mickey mouse comic
next to my chair so in case the game was
boring he knew that i would read it
instead of playing the game
my dad took that and
tweaked it worked on it this was sort of
an exciting moment for my dad
in the tuber family there's a bit of
competition my father would probably say
i'm the best player
no
sorry dad
benny is the best
there's a bit of a rivalry between my
dad and my brother
katan was officially released in germany
in 1994 and it was an immediate success
we had an immediate success in germany
because we won game of the year
worldwide to date over 24 million copies
have been sold this game was born out of
a story but it also creates stories the
beauty of catan is that in the end you
still have constructed something so in a
way everybody wins it was my wish to
have a very peaceful game with a lot of
interaction bringing people together for
me catan was the success
[Music]
to all the katan fans out there here's
some advice
well you always have to follow your
strategy but also you have to complain
quite a bit even though you know you're
winning you still have to say you're not
i love building cities as early as
possible in the game never built the
longest road at the beginning
and there you have it
[Music]
in many parts of the world scrabble is
viewed as a pastime as a game where
maybe old people play after retirement
and all that but scrabble in nigeria is
actually very big
it is seen as a sport there is an actual
nigerian scrabble federation under the
ministry of sports you have a lot of
young people hoping to end an actual
living from plain scrabble my name is
wellington jiggery and i'm the world
scrabble champion
i started playing scrabble in 1996 when
my immediate elder brother taught me the
game it wasn't until six years after
that i was playing with some of my
neighborhood friends and they were like
ah you are quite good why not
playing tournaments and i was like wow
you made it play this in tournaments and
the rest is history has to say
having an african windy world scrabble
championship is bigger than i can
actually comprehend you needed to have
been in the hall to see the jubilation
of our other african brothers it was
something that everyone in africa that
plays scrabble has actually looked
forward to
nigeria is a very very diverse nation we
have well over 500 developed languages
but the major means of communication all
over nigeria is english and since
scrabble is based upon the english
vocabulary it's going to be a way of
helping each and every one improve their
command of the english language so what
do you think we should play from here
if i hadn't played scrabble i might have
been involved in some other not so
legitimate activities and i think
playing scrabble it keeps you on the
right track okay good we are not
blind to the fact that the level of
unemployment in the country is very very
immense so i came up with the wellington
foundation for scrabble and mind
development in africa there's a lot
of
similarities between
how
life actually goes and how scrabble goes
you get to understand that it's not all
the time that you get things your way
you really have to make the best out of
the little that you are given
you know each country is known for a
particular spot brazil for example is
known for football we are hoping to make
scrabble a nigerian spot by if you
mention scrabble in any part of the
world nigeria should come to mind
[Music]
do
[Music]
ah first crushes we all remember them
and if you're a girl who grew up in the
90s your first crush might have been one
of the dream phone guys
oh boy
i think gary he has kind of a nice smile
yeah i'd say matt's probably a jock
this is mike gray the unlikely inventor
of the ultimate 90s tween dating game
we needed a game targeted towards
nine-year-old girls it was a bunch of
guys
that did it but that's
it is but i'm okay jealous
i said let's do something that's kind of
like clue so it's deduction we're going
to call a bunch of boys because we heard
some boy likes us
so it all started with the phone right
yes
we kind of laughed and we kind of called
this the pink slipper you know in its
day it was an elegant and beautiful
thing i know where he hangs out so how
did they pick the boys of your teenage
dreams we went to a photo house we
didn't know like who these boys were or
anything we just picked ones that we
liked
but that's not the only 90s girls game
mike made he also made the super
successful maul madness but he's pretty
real about his influence as a guy well
if i'm going to make a game about
shopping what i know about shopping you
just go get what you need and get back
to the car
later it was pointed out to me that
that's kind of not the way ladies shop
so it was kind of in a funny way a guy's
game you know
but it was for girls
i say games are togetherness in a box
play a game with people you learn a lot
about them and it shouldn't be about
winning and losing it should be about
being together